Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 77th episode!
BAU BAU!
For those who are joining us for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every
Every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag "hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning"!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Episode 77!
Extra lucky episode today!
BAU BAU!
Well... It may be extra lucky.
Extra lucky?
But... There's still been... Another Pero Sighting.
Where was Pero sighted this time?
Wow!
De-den!
Where is this?
Pero was seen with a bunch of other plushies.
Other plushies?
I mean, he does look like he fits in with them all.
But don't be fooled, Ruffians!
You know, he's not Calli.
He's not for sale.
I know you definitely do not want to welcome him into your home, okay?
No.
Yeah, absolutely not your bed either.
Also, you say he's been trying to grant you a wish?
Yeah.
We have been hearing reports of that, you know, ever since my birthday.
I wonder what kind of connection there could be.
Oh, but, well, uh... One thing, Ruffians!
One thing for sure is that he can't do anything like that.
Okay, after all, you know Pero.
Pero's just an old demon dog.
Yeah, he's not great or anything.
No, he's just nasty.
So no matter what he says, no matter what look he gives you, don't believe him, okay?
And definitely, definitely don't look into his little eyes there, okay?
No, okay.
You have to be careful, okay, Ruffians?
Don't trust him.
He's nasty.
BAU BAU!
Got it.
Yeah.
He's just a little guy, that's what you think, huh?
That's what he wants you to think, but... You have to listen to us.
Got it!
BAU BAU.
Wow, Ruffians.
That's been some...
Wow, Moco-chan.
It was your birthday, right?
You know, I sung a bunch of songs all on my own.
So I was really nervous.
And you know, I did my super chow reading all on my own for the first time ever too!
I was really nervous.
Thank you for being there for me!
Also!
I announced my first ever birthday merch!
BAU BAU!
I feel like I can't stress enough how excited I am for my birthday merch!
Both of ours, of course.
Of course, I'm also really excited about my own!
You know, I have a bunch of stuff here, you know?
Like my own special acrylic diorama stand!
But!
Not only is it super cute, but the illustration is done by Aoki Ume-sensei!
You know, the artist for Hidamari Sketch and I'm the character designer for Madoka Magica!
So please,
It's just amazing.
I'm so, so, so, so honored!
Right?
I mean, because it's a diorama, it's kind of like a figure, right?
Yeah, yeah!
Very cute.
You know, and I also have my Ruffian, the pink Ruffian.
Bless your heart.
I want to touch the toes.
So now we have the set, the blue and pink Ruffians.
I think, you know, the glasses are pretty cool, but
I like the tail!
Yeah!
Aw, the toe beads!
The tail, huh?
Yeah.
Touch the toes.
Yeah!
And you know they're both pretty big.
Huh?
I don't know about you, but I think big plushies are pretty nice, huh?
You could hug them!
Yeah!
Perfect for hugging!
And you know my t-shirt.
Very cute, but cool.
Says Mococo Abyssgard on the back there.
Yeah.
And then my special keychain.
Very very cute.
You know, my tail.
It's a rubber strap, but it's not actually my tail.
And my voice pack!
Cooking donuts together!
You know, if you get the complete set, you get a special appreciation voice as well!
So, please check it out.
I'd really like to be able to thank you properly with this.
You know, I know we talked about it before, but releasing amazing merch like this, you know, it's not a given to us at all, so we put a lot of thought and love into it.
We really hope you're just as excited about us to get your paws on it
You know both Fuwawa and my set!
BAU BAU!
Remember Ruffians, our birthday merch is only available for a limited time.
LIMITED TIME!
Until the beginning of March.
March is your deadline.
So please make sure not to miss out on them, okay?
Thank you so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so much Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
I got one for each sister!
Thank you!
Don't be sad, okay?
BAU BAU!
Such a good birthday.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Wow!
We also received ice cream from a Ruffian!
Thank you, too, for the impeccable reporting!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Something really, really cool happened, you know.
For some of our senpai.
One of our senpai, yeah.
And you might have missed the Ruffians, okay?
Did you?
Did you hear about this?
Wow.
Kanata-senpai!
She just released a brand new song written by the super famous music producer, Tsunku-san!
The song is called Junsui-shin.
Did you catch it, Ruffians?
You missed it?
Oh wow!
You took the scoop, you know.
Well, if you haven't heard of Tsunku-san before, he's famous for being the music producer of the
The legendary idol group Morning Musume and also the idol agency Hello!
Project too!
He's a producer that we really like and admire too.
So we're super surprised and happy for Kanata-senpai because we know that she really loves idols from Hello!
Project as well.
I saw on Twitter, I was like, oh my gosh, what did I just see?
Right!
But you know, this song is really, really cool, and it has a super strong Hello Project sound to it.
But also, surprisingly, some pretty awesome mecha fights in the ending too.
You need to check it out, okay, Ruffians?
If you missed it, especially, okay?
We also want to say a big congrats to Kanata-san!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
She must be so happy to have a song written for her by a producer like Tsunku-san and Chiyomaru-san.
Right!
That's the dream, huh?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I think you noticed this one, but recently a lot of our senpai
Recently, when Fubuki-senpai and Suisei-senpai were playing PAO World, they managed to catch two very, very rare and legendary PAOs.
You know, just like that, they look like big knights with fluffy tails.
I'm naming them!
They decided...
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
FUWAMOCO night's hot!
I know us!
We'll do our best to protect you smiles!
And I guess, got their other pals in PAL world too now, right?
And he's so sweet!
Only Fuwawa's horny!
Well, I think Moco-chan, you make a good Dark Knight, right?
Yeah, do I. Yeah, do I!
Dark Knight Fuwawa though.
Holy Night.
Mococo.
That could work too.
I don't know the difference.
BAU BAU!
BAU was so much fun though.
I got there up to a lot of fun and silliness.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, as you know, there's been so many special occasions going on recently, huh?
Yeah.
Well, I think we're all kind of aware of it by now, but Valentine's Day is just right around the corner.
Right!
And well to celebrate it, there's been some brand new hololive English merch that's just been released!
BAU BAU!
The lighted inquisim.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I think Ruffians are good!
It's pretty cute.
Ruffians, if you want to get a bit more into the Valentine's Day spirit, please check them out!
Okay?
You can find them on the hololive official store.
BAU BAU!
Valentine's Day, huh?
Yeah, but today's not Valentine's Day.
No!
Actually, today... It's Twin Day!
Yeah!
And, well, you know... We had some dreams, but... Why is it Twin Day, Moco-chan?
Oh, well... February 5th is Twin Day in Japan, you know?
Yeah.
I know it's not 5th anymore in Japan, but... Yeah, 2-5-5.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Our special day is for a week long, and you know, twin day is also kind of our special day too, so... There's a lot of fun celebration going on, but you know, also today is episode 77!
Double twin digits on twin day!
Extra special, right?
Later days always work out like this, huh?
But, we actually both had dreams last night.
Yeah.
We dreamt of each other!
Dreaming of double dreams and dreaming of each other on twin days is kinda weird, Ruffians, but...
Okay!
Yes, yes!
Well!
First up is my dream!
Mococo's dream!
So, recently, you know, we splurged a bit and we bought some sparkling water.
Because we really like it.
The one that we really like.
And it was on sale!
And you know, I've been saving mine in the fridge.
But, in my dream,
I dreamt that I went to go drink wine, and it was the last one in the fridge.
But, when I went to open it, I noticed that it was already half-dranken.
And then Fuwawa was like, oh sorry, I made a mistake.
And you know, drank some of the wine that you had there and then forgot about it and then drank a different bottle.
Sorry Moco-chan!
And that was really sad.
Why it's funny though?
Because I'm excited about the drink, but I don't think that I like it that much that I would dream about it, you know?
You know?
And rather than being sad in my dream that it was half-drinken, I was more sad that the fizziness was gone.
Things are silly, huh?
Drinking water.
Important dream, huh?
Fuwawa, how crazy you are!
I sound like a dark knight.
A dark knight who'll open up your fizzy water, take a drink, and then put it back and let it unfizz.
Darkness.
Well, for my dream, for Fuwawa's dream... Well...
It wasn't good.
Well, I jumped at, you know, we're doing a Rock n' Rawr Party.
Usually there's a lot of prep to do, so we just finished right in time before we need to press start.
But this time we kind of ran out of time and we were finally ready.
1 minute and 48 seconds after we had to press start.
Yeah, I was upset, but, you know, I couldn't really be helped.
But for some reason though, Moco-chan was like, no, I need to get other things done too.
I was starting to work on like prepping thumbnail stuff and like other things that wasn't really necessary.
And she just wouldn't start the stream.
Huh?
And finally, 7 minutes have passed, and I was able to convince her to do those things after.
7 minutes, you know?
And so then we started the stream, but I felt so bad, Ruffians.
You know, we kept you all waiting without any explanation too!
7 minutes, right!
Moco-chan.
And finally, 15 minutes to 8 AM.
Moco-chan finally decided to get moving, but we really had nothing prepped yet.
And I was just so upset at Moco-chan, and Moco-chan was so grumpy at me too.
I'm not grumpy.
You know we were barking at each other.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Uh-oh.
And it was just everything was the worst!
And then you know we're supposed to start and try and get, you know, all the Ruffians, we're supposed to start your day on the right paw and we were very much on the wrong paw and didn't have anything ready.
It was super rough, but
It was okay, actually, because Moco-chan woke me up very early.
This morning was like, Fuwawa, I woke up a bit early, but let's get going and have a good today.
A good day today.
A good today.
Okay, you know, just like that.
You know, let's get ready for FUWAMOCO Morning!
You know, I think us fighting like that in my dreams is more disturbing because that sort of thing never happens.
Dreams are funny, huh?
Yeah.
It was okay in the end.
Because it was just a dream, but... It's just a dream.
It's funny how things are like that, right?
Yeah.
Dreams are dreams.
They can be silly, huh?
Yeah, those were our twin dreams.
Our twin day!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I'm excited because, you know, it's February.
The first proper week, the first Monday in February.
And with every Monday, you know, it's a good time to challenge yourself because it's the beginning to a new week.
Which means today, Moco-chan's gonna challenge herself to eating some natto!
BAU BAU!
Just like every week, you know, for a long time now, Moco-chan, you've been trying something new.
Trying to overcome and conquer natto, which is a common breakfast food in Japan.
It consists of some fermented soybeans that's really, really, really healthy for you.
But it's a little bit of an acquired taste.
It's a little bit sticky.
And slimy.
And a bit stinky.
But, it's healthy for you.
FUWAMOCO eats everyday and Moco-chan wants to be a little bit more like her.
All this is to be able to pet your smile for many many years, just like me.
I just don't feel like eating today.
Well, there's a lot of Ruffians that want to challenge new things, but they're like, aw, baby, not today.
Right?
Just like Moco-chan, you're feeling not today.
I don't feel like it today.
Yeah.
But you're going to do it whether you feel like it or not.
Because sometimes that's half the battle, right?
Right, Ruffians?
Boy, my birthday rice today hot!
I'm gonna stir it up lots and lots because Moco-chan, I want you to eat lots and lots today.
I think it's in a really good condition.
It doesn't look that.
I woke up so nicely and then she goes, Moco-chan, I want you to eat lot and lot today.
Moco-chan, I'm gonna put some sesame oil in it too so you can eat lots right off the bat.
I really don't think I can.
Oh gosh, don't spill it everywhere!
Things are happening.
She's getting it everywhere!
I'm getting it everywhere.
With the sesame oil, oh it smells so good.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
It smells good, too.
Okay, Moco-chan, here you go!
Let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi who worked very hard to make this, okay?
Why?
It smells like sesame oil.
It's easy mode right now.
No, I just thought, just... Ruffians, it looks really different today.
It's not at all.
No, it really does.
You can do it, Moco-chan.
It looks really different to me.
It looks really soupy.
And sticky.
You can do it, Moco-chan!
No complaining, okay?
I can see the oil boiling.
The oil is all piling up at the bottom of the pan!
Just add a bit more, Mococo.
No!
I got this, Mococo!
The oil is making it even more sticky and good.
It'll be good.
Pick up a couple beans, okay?
You've been eating one bean average.
Without the sesame oil.
That's already amazing!
Moco-chan, at least two, okay?
They have sesame oil in it.
I made a baby bowl for you.
One bean after another.
Yeah.
Beans and concession, okay?
Okay, I'm gonna try!
Go for it, Moco-chan!
I believe in you!
Okay.
I'm not stalling!
I'm gonna try!
One for twin day, two for twin day.
Yup, yup, yup.
I'm gonna try, okay.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Three!
Two!
One!
No, no.
Do it, Moco-chan.
The plane went in and then went out.
No.
Moco-chan!
Three!
Two!
I dropped it.
You didn't drop it.
I picked it back up.
I did drop it.
Three!
Two!
One!
Okay, okay.
It landed.
The plane landed.
She's chewing it.
That's cool.
Good job, Moco-chan.
You're chewing it.
Nice one!
Okay!
I stomped it down.
Good job, Moco-chan!
The second bead is in the chopsticks!
I made sure the good chopsticks are good.
Why is it, why is it, why is it...
Awesome!
Okay.
You're doing it.
You can do it!
You can do it, Moco-chan!
Don't give up!
You can do it!
You're strong, Popo!
Yeah!
Okay!
Oh no, Moco-chan!
I did it!
Are you crying?
It was very difficult, but I did it!
I'm so proud of you, Moco-chan!
I don't have tears now!
A twin did too, B!
Give me the water!
Please.
Please!
Give me the water, please!
BAU BAU!
That was rough, wasn't it?
You look troublesome today.
I'm not crying, okay?
You did a good job, Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
No fizzy water.
Is he not the water?
I don't know about that.
Good job, Moco-chan!
Well, Ruffians, you know that was Moco-chan's best attempt at eating natto for this week.
Please remember, you know, no matter how much you might not want to do it, today's the day, okay?
Let Moco-chan's hard work guide you to working hard at whatever you need to challenge, okay?
Mococo amazing.
Proud of her as always.
BAU BAU!
I'm looking forward to the leftovers too.
Let's see who is the Doggie of the Day today.
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
Ponzu really loves the hot carpet.
The hot carpet.
It's a hot climate.
You know it's perfect on a cold winter morning, right?
Chihuahua kana?
Fuwawa chihuahua janai yo.
It's not chihuahua.
It's, you know, hot ponzu.
Toasty ponzu.
Well ponzu's charm point is a little white toes too.
Yeah.
Doggy song!
Right!
Ponzu has doggy songs!
BAU BAU!
Wow, Moco-chan, how do you think ponzu BAU BAU?
Maybe a bit... Sweet.
But a bit sour.
Ah, citrusy.
BAU BAU BAU!
I think it's a good mix, huh?
Zesty, yeah.
Zesty BAU BAU.
Well, Ponzu, you know, Ponzu's an obvious cutie.
Very much looks like a citrusy little Ponzu-chan!
And, you know, Ponzu loves cuddling and getting warm hugs from you, I'm sure.
And I think, you know, those eyes.
I can see those eyes say, I like
BAU BAU!
Today I went on a walk.
Where did we go?
De-den!
Such a cool tropical walk.
And coming across a magical little stream of magical nature too.
I bet all the nature sounds are so relaxing.
I like to hear it, huh?
It's like BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
We had a nice time there, you know.
Reconnecting with the world and nature.
BAU BAU!
And today, we received a question!
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Oh!
It went so fast!
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
Question from a Ruffian who loves you both.
I never wanted to pick favorites, but with things like the blue pink version Ruffians and separated birthdays, I've been wondering, do you actually like it when we pick one?
Maybe it'll let each of you feel special.
BAU BAU.
This is a tricky question, but a good one!
Yeah, it's hard, right?
We want your love us both more than anything, you know?
Yeah, so we'd rather not have you pick between us, but if you do... We understand, you know.
I guess it's natural heart.
Yeah, but maybe keep it a bit of a secret from us, too.
But you know, I love Moco-chan!
Yeah, and...
I'm a Fuwawa too.
It is twin day, I'll say it.
Thank you.
But, well, you know, it's also nice to have our own very special days too.
You know, to be recognized as individuals too.
We're not only FUWAMOCO, you know, also FUWAWA.
And Mococo-e.
But together we are FUWAMOCO!
So like we kind of said before, if FUWAMOCO is your oshi, then actually you have three oshi!
Fuwawa, Mococo, and FUWAMOCO!
But you know, we also know it's natural.
Hello!
Thank you so much for all your submissions today, Ruffians!
Please, we're always looking
Time for more Doggie of the Day questions!
Your questions, Pero Sightings, your vlogs, all of it!
So please use the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Also your scoops too!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
For our next stream tonight, we have De-den!
We're going to be over on Reine-senpai's channel for the first time.
It's just going to be us three!
We're super excited because Reine-senpai is going to be teaching us Indonesian.
Actually, no Ruffians.
We went a little bit before and it was a lot of fun.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
We're gonna have a bunch of fun!
For sure!
BAU BAU!
Alright, let me take a peek at this week's schedule.
On Tuesday, we're gonna be playing some more Metal Gear Solid 2.
Now Moco-chan, you've been doing better and better.
Your sneaking and your shooting skills, right.
Yes.
But, uh, well, we weren't really able to save the president like we first set out to do.
Oh well.
Too bad.
Yeah, you know there's other important objectives in our mission now too, so we're gonna do our best!
BAU BAU!
Don't be confused, Ruffians!
Another FUWAMOCO Morning isn't starting today!
But the day is just beginning, okay?
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Yatto takoyaki!
BAU BAU!
Yari no ame!
It's money!
BAU BAU!
White school!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!